the first marijuana commercial was set
to air on US television in the state of
Colorado first Monday night then it was
moved to tonight now it has been
postponed indefinitely the advertisement
hitting a legal nerve state regulations
have set the bar of acceptance very high
Ramey
innocencio brings us this Bloomberg
exclusive the very first look at the TV
ad before it airs anywhere else yeah
that's exactly right we got it airing
just in a couple seconds but of course
want to talk about Colorado it makes
sense that the first television ad is
going to air because Colorado was the
first in the nation to actually legalize
recreational marijuana right now it is
one of 23 states including the District
of Columbia that actually has legalize
marijuana so I do want to get to this ad
right now it's just a 15-second ad so
let's go ahead and roll back you lead an
adventurous life always finding new ways
to relax
now enjoy the best effects and control
with Neos portable vape pen and read
create discreetly this summer Neos read
create responsibilities you lead an
adventurous I mean I love that they that
they have easy just break this down for
a minute sure does we need advertising
you know people want to make money off
of it clearly and there is a ton out
there that ad that you just saw costs in
the range of about ten thousand ten
thousand or so from what I'm sold
versus the hundreds of thousands that
other ads could command but with that
said I do want to ask looking at this ad
right now what do you not see guides we
don't see weed no plants no cannabis
products not even the vape pen that
they're trying to advertise and that's
because of the state regulations in
Colorado there it's so high that they
can't even talk about and that's example
I wasn't yes
somebody must believe that this is going
to bring people to pot because you ask
that question and I think I laugh and I
think to myself oh and then flomax right
why does flomax need to advertise if
you're an old man and you can't pee
right like surely you want flomax yeah
but you might not be aware that flomax
exist exist they've been growing it in
their garages for years in terms of the
amount of money that is in the weed
economy brightfield group which
researches this says it is comparable to
the alcohol industry coming in at more
than a billion dollars so there is so
much money clearly that we know that can
already be made here interestingly
though with this looking ahead we don't
know when this ad is going to go out
because interestingly ABC at the local
level in Colorado approached this
company neos as well as canna brand
which is the PR agency and said hey we
want Hana brass cannon red-hot specific
advertising yes canna brand and is the
it bills itself as the first PR
cannabis company like this let's just
take a moment for a second this never
happened when pot was illegal there
wasn't an echo system of this nature
around it I mean and it's going to
of course that happens right oh here's
this thing but you know we need
advertising we need marketing we need
lobbyists we need specialist troops I
just think people who are there really
need
bank accounts there you go people want
to smoke weed find it they will find it
but you know right now just looking at
this we just don't know when it's going
to air ABC corporate has actually put a
stop putting a suspension to the ABC
state level and one of the things the
legality of airing federally illegal
substance on basically federally
controlled channels the FCC obviously
here so it's a thing between the federal
and the state level but you know again
24 country 24 states including the
District of Columbia it's likely to get
even higher no pun intended so who knows
where we are in five or ten years this
might be something that we're going to
be seeing on air you know say hey maybe
we got to leave it there a training
innocencio